hello welcome to everybody for our
webinar today on product management and
ask us anything session with anand
subramani and joyanna zhang
both experienced product executives
uh anand right now is the vp of product
at path and jay-z is the vp of product
at webflow so today's session will be q
a driven so you should see a little q a
box in your in your interface just type
a question in there it's a short session
we may not get to all the questions
during it but keep keep the questions
coming
uh and
with that i think actually we'll just
get it kicked off so we don't waste any
more time so
anon we we spoke this time last year and
i should mention there are links to our
previous webinars as well if you want to
see uh what non-jay-z have had to say
before about product management
one question that came up last year was
how has product management changed with
the move to fully remote work and you
said and i'm paraphrasing a little bit
here a small organization organization
has to act like a big organization it's
harder to run things ad hoc when
everyone is remote so you need to
develop the processes and deliberate
communication practices that you'd
expect in a larger organization
i love this answer because
it related to your core principle of the
product manager being the glue in an
organization responsible for inter and
intra team communication so a year on is
there anything you would add to that
answer
any new insights
sure um for a tiny bit of context uh
path is remote first and remote forever
so this is a thing that we have had to
figure out as a company um
two things that really jump out to me
one of them is about
the first is about
asynchronous and synchronous
communication asynchronous communication
is talking over slack or it's writing
emails or it's writing documents
synchronous usually means in person
my lived experience with this is
synchronous communication is much higher
bandwidth if there's a complicated topic
or something you need to work through
with someone it is so much faster and so
much more effective to quote get in a
room with them whether that means a
virtual conference or a physical room
so i think you know two years into into
remote work one of the things i think
has become even more important for
product managers is to know which mode
to be in and make it really easy to be
in the appropriate one
a tactical example what that means for
us um we use slack and zoom as our tools
of communication there's a magic command
in slack zoom that automatically starts
a conference we use that all the time i
probably use it 25 times a day
so it's making sure that you're not
forcing yourself into a
six paragraph conversation with someone
when really what you need is a five
minute conversation um i think it's a
high premium on knowing which mode you
should be in
um the second one is
this just continues to be more and more
true but
documenting things is even more
important than it ever was and it was
always important but i would say most
companies ours included tend to do this
poorly historically with people being in
different time zones and often having
never met each other writing things down
is more important than it's ever been
whether that means making a little video
recording a zoom making a loom putting
it on youtube writing whatever it is
archiving and saving that information is
more important than it's ever been
thanks anan jay-z is there anything you
would add to anon's answer
sure um i i do say that slash zoom as a
shortcut shortcut command in slack is
probably one of the best tips i've
personally gotten and i give my team so
if you don't know that write that down
um to add on this concept of really
documenting decision making it is
something that is going to help you move
a lot faster it might not feel like it
at the very beginning when you're
writing that document but as your
company scales as new people come on
having that documentation whether it's
you know this is my prd my product
requirements document this is the
meeting notes of when we had to make a
really important decision this is the
decision we made i'm having a wiki for
your company where all of this can live
for the product team for your area all
of those things are just becoming more
and more important
that's great and i want to remind people
to continue to submit questions in the q
and a box we're already getting uh some
great ones
but i want to stay a little bit here on
on this topic and uh follow up we have a
good follow-up question and it's related
again to one of your core principles
with so jay-z you talk about
bringing the donuts right the pm's
responsibility for team morale
how have you been doing that when
everybody's remote what are some of the
challenges and opportunities there
yeah i think the first thing to stress
is that bringing the donuts is really
just a concept right you know you can
physically bring in donuts but the
concept is how do you make sure that
your team feels appreciated they feel um
cohesive and so even in a remote world
you know you can do this whether that is
through still physical things like
mailing people thank you notes i know
that might feel old school and
old-fashioned but it actually really can
mean something you know in today's world
it's very a digital and remote we did
something recently where we actually
mailed people uh polaroids and had them
take pictures of their family
of things that they loved and then we
sent them back we had them send the
pictures back and then we digitized it
and so just creating that connection
another thing that you can do um with
your team is you know bringing the
donuts really means celebrating great
work right and and cheering your team on
so that can take the form of um
props right so in your slack channel or
email or whatever you're using really
celebrating those moments um shouting
out people who've done a really great
job who've done something really
difficult um who've gone above and
beyond those are types of things that
you can do in a world where bringing the
donuts a little bit harder when we're
all physically together
anon is there anything you would add to
this idea of bringing the donuts in this
remote world
just one which is um this might sound
corny but don't be afraid to formalize
the concept
one of the things that
we've done that has worked pretty well
is we have an explicit concept of a
rotating person every month who's in
charge of doing something team oriented
and team related and they
plan an event or
totally up to them it's their discretion
um but we formalized a little bit and
while it might sound silly and might
sound a little bit dumb
people walk out of those and like
actually i had a really good time
meeting my co-workers so the team
building and the team bonding event of
this
can also be formalized a bit to make
sure that it is somebody's job and that
you are actually doing it
and anon i want to stay with you for a
little bit longer so we're we're getting
a lot of questions now about the core
what are the core skills that you need
to improve on as a pm and what are the
common mistakes and so i want to try and
bring these together around the core
uh you know core responsibilities of apm
which is knowing your customer so
you argue you've got to really be the
customers advocate in the organization
so could you talk a little bit about
what that means and what are the common
pitfalls that young pms or new pms make
when they're trying to know the customer
sure um in terms of what it means it
means that
one of the things you are uniquely
responsible for is representing your
customer inside the building as you are
making products or as you're going
through some prioritization process
in terms of the most common way that i
see this fail especially for new product
managers it's doing a very large project
to know your customer and then assuming
that you're done
it's doing a bunch of research and then
a year from now you're saying we did
that research project a year ago we
already know our customer this is the
thing you have to do to perpetuity and
it requires constant refreshing this
information i think it's about building
systems where you are constantly
connecting with your customers all the
time even all the way up to an executive
level um i do three to five customer
calls every week and will till the end
of time just making sure that you have a
consistent check in with your customers
not just a one-time check-in with your
customers
and now can i ask a quick follow-up on
that are those customer calls the same
as when you're doing focus group work as
when you're doing customer interviews or
are these
different level of formality or
casualness what you know i know this is
a common how do you build up that skill
of learning about your customers so it'd
be great to talk a little bit more about
the structure of those customers
it really depends um i'd say there's
definitely a few different archetypes
one archetype is an escalation a
customer had some frustrating experience
um i've sort of put the word out to
people on our team that if someone has a
frustrating experience with the product
you can put them in touch with me
directly so there's definitely one
archetype that's i had a problem i want
to talk to a very senior person on the
team i want to feel heard and i also
want to know that you're taking your
problem seriously and this is actually
really phenomenal for sort of cutting
through stuff that gets lost in the
organization
where nobody in the organization feels
empowered to fix it i can talk to a
customer and say great we're fixing this
tomorrow um that's one archetype i'd say
a second archetype is uh i have a topic
that i'm interested in and i want to do
something exploratory about it
at path for example we're starting to
think about how we can better support
therapists
i have calls over the next few weeks
with people who are not path customers
but are therapists who have recently
started their own practice and i have a
script that i've written where i'm going
to go in to talk about the topics on my
mind the last one um before i kick it
over to jay-z is uh
sort of informal like there isn't a
specific thing you want to talk about um
and here i have a script that i usually
write and just keep running through
about tell me what's working well in the
product tell me what's not working well
tell me what you wish existed tell me if
you recommend it to a friend it's really
just a basic overview of what's going on
and then how you use it in your
day-to-day life there's a lot of day in
the life type questions and how you make
use of the questions
that's great that's really helpful jay-z
is there anything you would add to the
sort of knowing your customer
skill
yeah what i would say here and i'm gonna
pivot a little bit to some of the
questions that i do see coming in um
which are really around you know how do
you transition
your career right if you're doing x role
if you're doing operations if you're
doing um like you know business stuff um
how do you transition into the product
management role um when you can be
when you can really understand your
customer right so whether um you're
working on qa or whether you are um
you know working in operations but you
take the time to deeply understand what
your customer needs um that gives you an
advantage in making that transition
because product
management really is about understanding
that that user and really knowing like
what are their pain points where they
really struggling with so i just wanted
to address that a little bit i know that
those are some of the questions that are
coming in the other piece and i also see
people asking about hey you know i have
a business background i um you know i'm
currently um in consulting or i went to
business school like how do i make that
transition the other piece of the
product management role is not just
understanding your user but it's really
understanding the business context is
there an opportunity here like yes there
is user pain and if we built something
we could capture look we can serve that
user pain but also capture a real
opportunity in the market and so when
you lean into both of those the deep
understanding of the user and that
opportunity for the business that's when
you really provide value as a product
manager and so that is what you can lean
into based on your respective
backgrounds in order to transition to
the product management role
that's really great and i i wanted to
follow up on that so so jay-z may be
sticking with you here this is a
question that came in that i thought was
a
nicely worded which is if we do a little
pre-mortem on a product manager who's
just started the role and now they're
really struggling let's say six months
in what what would you say what is it
that's causing them to struggle what do
you typically see as a new pm struggling
in those first six months of their role
yeah
i think the first thing is a lot of
times
uh the pm role at a given company is not
well defined and that is because the pm
role can be a little bit different based
on the company based on your product
based on your users and what that
company needs and so one of the biggest
reasons why
you know new pms might be struggling is
because their role definition and what
they're responsible is not necessarily
clear um not just to them but also to
the organization more broadly and so one
of the things i'd really encourage um
upms is take the time work with your
manager and really define what success
looks like and you know if you do take
our course you can really start to see
this is what it means to really own the
product lifecycle this is what it really
means to be successful and so taking
some of those tips you can actually
write down hey this is what success
looks like as a new pm you know in my
first 90 days in my first six months in
my first year um so that's that's one
thing i think another thing is you know
it's there are times actually it's quite
easy to be on projects where um it's not
clear what user problem you're solving
for or you can be on project where even
though there's user pain there isn't a
clear business opportunity so even if
you built something that's delightful
it's actually not gonna have a lasting
impact on the business and so when both
of those things are not true
for your project that is also a reason
why things can go um awry and and how
people could be not so successful in
their first year and so really just
understanding like having the tools to
understand is that happening here with
my project with what i'm working on
that's another big thing to really get
right in order to be successful
anon is there anything you would add to
this what do you see as the the major
struggles if you're doing a pre-mortem
for a new pm after six months they're
really struggling what styles
i think this is a manifestation of
jay-z's first point but it also
addresses some of the other uh comments
that have been brought up in the
questions missions um it's really easy
as a new pm to be entirely reactive
instead of proactive
boss comes to you and says do this
founder of the company comes to you and
says what if we did this thing and you
spend all of your time responding to
outside requests and no time taking your
projects and moving your projects
forward so i think there's a bunch of
questions here about what are some of
the skills required to know if you will
be a successful product manager and what
are some of the skills to start working
on now i think one of the absolute core
skills to be successful at this role is
being able to center yourself on your
job is to deliver value to customers and
user excuse me the customers and the
business simultaneously you do that by
making stuff
and you need to be super proactive about
taking things from start to finish not
just about being responsive to whatever
the organization happens to be asking
today
it's very easy for organizations to
generate a lot of chaos
and you need to wrangle that but if that
becomes your full-time job you're not
moving your project forward
and on there's a question that came in
that i think is a really nice uh
follow-on to this which is again another
one of the core
skills that you identify as being able
to influence without authority so how do
you get buy-in for your role how do you
how do you influence when you're getting
all these requests coming in and you
need to build some space to to
proactively pursue your projects how do
you
influence without authority i know
that's a million dollar question if you
had an easy answer you know it would be
a different world but what are some of
the strategies and tactics that you use
for influencing without authority
everyone very much develops a big part
of their own personal style on this i
think a big one that i learned early in
my career is you can be responsive to
sort of a bunch of these requests coming
in
without it taking up all of your time so
the influence of that authority piece is
sometimes learning to gently redirect
things to the right place
or to let something sit longer than it
should or not get back to something
right away so that you are focusing on
the most important thing so i think the
influence of that authority piece is all
about striking this delicate line of
getting the rest of the organization
what it needs to continue
without having that eat up all of your
hours in the day
if anybody here is a product manager at
a larger company i'm guessing you spend
almost all of your hours on the day
interfacing with the rest of the
organization and it's about being
defensive to get some of that time back
jay-z what would you add to this idea of
influencing authority without authority
uh it's easy to influence with authority
without authority what are some of your
tactics and strategies
yes
so um we do say this which is being a pm
is not a solo sport
it is a team sport right so you are a pm
you will have an engineering manager or
partner or tech lead you will have a
design partner you have a lot of other
stakeholders and so a large part of the
influence without authority is having
strong relationships with your team um
with your your partners right and
knowing when it is
you need to push something forward
versus you need to encourage your your
teammate to own something and push it
forward and so
while you don't manage all the designers
on the team your design manager who's
your partner does well you don't manage
all the engineers on your team the
engineering manager on your team does
right so you can when you have those
relationships you can influence those
particular stakeholders to then directly
manage those who are solid line
reporting up to them um to get things
done so i think that's a huge piece and
then i think cross-functionally this is
across the team um you know the pm team
while does feel kind of lonely in terms
of like you are the pm in your area
there isn't really another pm you are
usually part of a pm organization right
so there's another pm on other projects
you have you know group pms directors vp
so on and so forth and so your pm team
is a really huge asset bringing things
early and often to the pm team finding
best practices for that pm team to be
really gelled and cohesive and you know
synced in their strategy that really
helps you get things done because
instead of you constantly trying to get
a million stakeholders aligned you can
leverage the pms across the organization
to all move in unison and so that is a
huge piece of also creating that network
effect and influencing across the
company
that's that's really uh that's really
interesting uh yeah and it's always you
know one of the things i think we all
struggle with it's one of the hardest
skills um i want to pivot so i do want
to save some time because we're getting
so many of those questions around how do
i transition and what does it mean you
know what does it mean to be a pm but
there is one other question that came in
that i want to ask you jay-z uh before
pivoting to that question and that's
is there a difference or what is the
difference between
being a pm for a new product and
potentially a new product in a new
industry you know we got a question if
this there's no industry for this what
are the benchmarks versus being a
product manager when you're coming into
a company maybe the pm for an
established product so what the core
question is
is there and what is the difference
between being a pm for a new product
and an established product
yeah i'll start with first the
similarities right so as a pm regardless
of what product you're on you have to
deeply understand
your users again we're gonna sound like
a broken record um and also the business
opportunity if you don't understand that
whether you're building something brand
new or you're you know trying to add to
an existing product but you know shape
it evolve it in the way um that is most
impactful you can't do either of those
successfully if you don't have a
fundamental understanding of who are you
building for what do they need and am i
going to actually have a meaningful
impact there such that it becomes a
business opportunity
that being said there are definitely
some differences right so with a new
product um you know the things i would
really advise pms to really focus on is
you know what is the state of the world
today in terms of just alternatives like
what like who are the competitors that
you think your audience is going to be
using um you know what if there are no
competitors what are the you know work
around solutions that people are kind of
gluing together that you think you can
do a much better job at those are the
things you really look at when you're
building something zero to one when
you're building something that is more
established you actually have the
benefit of having so much data you don't
have to necessarily go outside of the
company and try to do these like
benchmarks or approximations you can
actually work with your data team you
can go directly and see you know how are
people using these features in the past
how do i segment my cohorts
what is working what isn't working what
what is the what is the data the logging
um our you know our charts really say
about what's going on here and so that's
another that's a big difference that i
think when you're working on an existing
product to really leverage and focus on
so that you can actually make the best
decisions going forward for how to
evolve it
that's great uh
anan would you add anything uh to this
question
established product versus new i'll do
20 seconds and then i think a lot of
people are interested in how they become
a pm so 20 seconds on this um
just expanding on what jc said at the
beginning i think a huge difference is a
new product fits more into the context
of the rest of their life and an
existing product often fits into the
context of itself if you're a pm working
on a feature at a huge established
product google or microsoft or whatever
a lot of your work will be how does this
thing fit into the other parts of the
product that we control um and if you
are in a former category it's all about
fitting your product into the rest of
their life are they going to use things
at work or at home for personal or for
play
what are the replacement solutions what
are competitors so the context in which
your thing fits is pretty different and
that puts a different premium on where
you spend your time
perfect thank you anon and jay-z i want
to come back to you so again you know
lots and lots of questions about how do
i become a pm and you've already
addressed some of it you know finding
that marriage between business you know
what's good for the business and what
and and knowing your customer
what other what other advice would you
provide in terms of making that
transition from
from different roles into the product
management role what should people be
thinking about
yeah um
i think someone actually brought this up
in chat where
they said you know it is really tricky
because one of the best ways to get a
job is to already have the pm title and
it becomes this cash 22. um so that is
true but a couple ways to think about
this is um you know first if you're at a
company and you're really excited to
transition to a pm role at that
particular company i think what you do
is really find that wedge where you're
adding value to an existing team whether
it's more on the business side whether
it's more on the understanding the user
side right like i am um a designer and i
really understand the user transitioning
from that into product management or i'm
a data scientist and i really understand
you know how
or um you know how our product works but
also the intersection of how our users
are using this product that is something
that's an asset for you to transition
into the pm role if you're going to do
this um
at a completely new company right if you
don't see those opportunities at your
existing company one of the things that
anand and i do advise
people to do is sometimes when you go
smaller there are more opportunities to
to really just wear multiple hats you
know when you're at a small company you
might be doing a little bit of
operations and you might be doing a
little bit of product and over time you
do more product and officially become a
pm and so that's another opportunity to
think about which is can you find it at
your existing company or do you need to
potentially look at a different company
and based on the opportunities at that
company to make that transition
and i want to give you a second to add
anything to jay-z's answer but i do also
want to ask you about some of the formal
learning experiences that you and jay-z
have put together around classes so
anything you would add to jay-z's
response before talking about kind of
formal ways of learning about pm
just an expansion of her first point
which is if you're new to the product
discipline uh
you probably don't know a lot about
product management you have to bring
some other asset you need to be super
intellectually honest about the other
asset that you bring the most common two
assets that i see for you who transition
to this are either are one people who
know a lot about the customer most
common roles here are sales roles
customer service roles customer support
roles people who spend all day talking
to the customer tend to know a lot about
the customer i mean i know about product
management but that's the trade you know
a ton about the customer somebody else
will teach you about product management
um the other one is on the business side
um some of this comes out of sales
somebody comes out of business school
some of the kind of consulting um it's
knowing a ton about
both how this business works and how
business works in general and again the
trade is i bring that skill and you
teach me product management
well that's that's a perfect segue so i
guess my follow-up question and we're
running out of time i know you both have
to go back to work and we all everyone
else probably on this call does too you
do
you and jay-z have put together both a
asynchronous course a self-paced course
on product management you're also
teaching a graduate level course at
stanford that is open uh to enrollment
and if people are interested there
there's a link there in the interface
you can click on that you can enroll can
you talk about those two courses and
what the different audiences are and
while you're doing that i'm actually
going to launch a poll just to learn a
little bit more about our audience and
what kind of learning experiences
they're interested in which can help us
refine what we offer
sure um i'd say the biggest difference
between the two of them is the
self-paced online class is sort of like
the
video analog of a textbook
you're doing it by yourself you're doing
it at your own pace the time commitment
is relatively old low it's on the order
of a dozen hours
it's whatever you uh put in is what you
will get out but i would think of it as
sort of a
it's like a textbook
the in-person graduate class is
much more expensive you will work with a
team which is better representative how
product managers work in real life it
will take a real project from start to
finish you will go through product
reviews and design reviews um it's much
longer so it's probably on the order of
uh
five to 15 hours a week of work um so
think of the the online class as sort of
the equivalent of getting a textbook and
reading a textbook and the other one is
more like going to school for an entire
quarter on how to do this as well
jc is there anything you would add to
the differences in those two
those two formal learning experiences
um i mean i think those are really those
are the key ones um boiling it down to
your time commitment right like how much
time of your day can you actually carve
out to really um spend with this um you
know if you don't have a lot of time we
definitely recommend the online version
it is self-paced and it will give you a
lot of the frameworks you need um but
but at you know in a digestible way at
the pace you need and then the other one
is when you're like i want to go all in
i want a more immersive experience and i
learn best by partnering and really
trying to do as opposed to um you know
reading or watching
great um we're running up on time i do
want to mention there was one question
the graduate course you can
you enroll and then there are we review
the applications based on prerequisites
and and your background so it is
competitive but it's not it is an actual
stanford class and it's not like
applying to stanford right it's not that
it's not that competitive um is there
anything else you jay-z would want to
add we're in our last two minutes again
the the biggest question we get are
about you know preparing yourself for a
product management role is there
anything else it may be something you
wish you had done before you started
your first pm role that you would want
to share with everybody here
yeah um
i think one of the reasons why anand and
i have worked so hard to create these
courses is because a lot of the
learnings that we really wish we had
when we started off our careers we
wanted to actually put down for the next
you know all the other folks who are
trying to make that transition or
starting to learn about product
management
sorry just hit the mute button but um
that's why we created these courses
because we wanted to all the things we
actually you know
if we were to go back in time and say
what did you wish you knew back when you
first started when you were trying to
make the transition when you're in your
first couple years of product management
you know what we've created really tries
to capture that essence and so i would
say
some of that um the other thing is i
would say a community so one of the the
best things um
one of the best ways to continue to
strive towards what you're hoping to do
is to find other people who are also
trying to make the same transitions who
are um
potentially going through some of these
struggles as a new pm they're trying to
learn these things um and what you get
with that community with more people
that you can talk to is you can get more
reps in much faster so instead of you
sitting alone with your kind of problem
and your users if you find other people
maybe it's through communities like this
you can actually see what people are
struggling with and see those reps um
like more frequently and then learn from
even how other people are doing it so
the last piece beyond just all the stuff
that we've kind of pulled down is that
community aspect and finding like
partners that you want to keep in touch
with they can check back in with on
their journey and their learnings as
pm's both new pms but also you know
mentors who are a little more
experienced a few years beyond where you
want to be
great and we are we are at time i want
to do it and on i want to give you a
chance to have the last word i did want
to address a question about the graduate
live class it's not in person it is a
remote class the lectures are recorded
during uh during the sessions and then
you you can if i remember right now the
way it's set up you watch the lectures
after the fact you don't need to
participate live but there is group work
that you would then be doing every week
keeping up with the class on that so it
is the actual class being broadcast uh
to to students
um okay anon is there anything you want
to add last word you want to get in uh
on on this session
yeah um
i'll add one about uh
practice being a great writer it's
always been a great pm spend a third of
their time talking a third of their time
listening and a third of their time
writing
and there are infinite opportunities
practice being a great writer everybody
writes emails everybody writes documents
take a moment and practice the craft of
writing being a persuasive clear and
concise with an emphasis on concise
communicator is a totally critical skill
and this thing you can do in any job
anywhere
that's a great that's a great ending to
it so anan jay-z thank you so much for
your time today thank you everyone who
joined us we didn't get to all the
questions uh we will undoubtedly be
doing another webinar at some point with
anon and jay-z and so there'll be more
opportunities to learn from them and uh
thank you again everybody we really
appreciate you being
you